su columna vertebral está compuesta de
huesos individuales llamados vértebras
sus vértebras forman un túnel protector
llamado canal medular
el cual rodea la médula espinal mientras
recorre toda su columna vertebral a cada
lado de la médula espinal los nervios
espinales salen del canal medular a
través de canales pequeños y óseos
llamados forámenes neurales
y los nervios de la columna cervical
viajan a través de su cuello hombros y
brazos
entre su cráneo y su cavidad torácica
hay siete vértebras que forman su
columna cervical
y almohadillas flexibles conocidas como
discos intervertebrales brindan
amortiguación entre sus vértebras para
el rango de movimientos que su cabeza y
cuello realizan todos los días la
columna cervical soporta el peso de su
cabeza permite que su cabeza rote y se
incline y lo ayuda a doblar su cuello la
presión en los discos cervicales aumenta
cuando su cuello se dobla hacia adelante
hacia atrás y hacia los lados
y los discos intervertebrales consisten
de un fuerte anillo exterior de tejido
llamado anillo fibroso y de un centro
suave y gelatinoso llamado el núcleo
pulposo
durante una lesión traumática su columna
puede forzarse hacia adelante o hiper
flexionarse causando que sus vértebras
comprima en el frente de uno o más de
sus discos cervicales más allá de
límites normales la hiper flexión del
cuello es una causa común de lesión
cervical que ocurren accidentes de
vehículos motorizados y en algunos
deportes como resultado su núcleo
pulposo gelatinoso es empujado hacia
atrás hacia su anillo fibroso reduciendo
el grosor de su anillo y causando
pequeñas fisuras
luego de una lesión en los discos
cervicales su anillo fibroso comienza a
debilitarse y agrietarse y su núcleo
pulposo se torna seco y rígido luego de
un tiempo estos cambios hacen que su
disco sea susceptible a más lesiones
conforme su disco intervertebral se
deteriora un anillo fibroso débil puede
permitir que su núcleo pulposo se
proteja cambiando la forma y
flexibilidad normales del disco
dependiendo de su ubicación la
producción puede empujar o pensar uno de
sus nervios espinales
o su médula espinal causando dolor e
inflamación
y la protusión discal central se
proyecta hacia atrás en su canal medular
la producción discal lateral se extiende
en su foramen neural varias lesiones
severas del disco cervical pueden
desgarrar su anillo fibroso la presión
de su vértebra puede empujar su núcleo
pulposo hacia fuera del anillo
desgarrado lo que causa la hernia ción
discal
un disco herniado puede pinchar sus
nervios espinales o médula espinal
interrumpir las señales nerviosas
normales y causar síntomas como dolor
entumecimiento o debilidad en uno o
ambos brazos
el tratamiento para las lesiones del
disco cervical puede incluir descanso
medicamentos antiinflamatorios
relajantes musculares hielo o calor
aplicado al área lesionada fisioterapia
inyecciones de esteroides y en casos más
severos cirugía